Facebook rolled out a new mode aimed at
creators that you could choose to switch
on it kind of overlays on top of your
personal profile if they're like a
Creator type an entrepreneur an
influencer they are getting
significantly more reach to get access
to all the monetization tools however I
switched to professional mode and I saw
this huge lovely Spike and reach and
then it just started to taper off after
about 6 months so I actually chose to
switch it back to Classic after speaking
to a gentleman and he was like you know
what I went back to Classic and I saw
way more reach and I'm like really I'm
do the same and same thing happened to
me I got more reach on classic